oh mein gott wie kisten jetzt und immer
noch kein schild bitte hier
ja
besonders willkommen zu einem neuen
video heute spielen wir mal einen modus
den ist schon lange nicht mehr gab
ob diese schneiden und zwar ksg was
daran liegt dass ich einfach ko sg ein
kleines bisschen hasse das so eine
hassliebe einerseits mag ich es weil es
mega actionreich ist andererseits hatte
ich zwei mal einfach kein treffer kommt
und dann von ihnen ab gestoppt wird
genauso wie hier
und dass ich weiß nicht also für alle
die kuh sg spieler werdet wahrscheinlich
selbst kennt toll ich toll toll ich
mache fünf kisten auf und komplett wert
ok ja gut wenn ihr mich nicht nicht ich
wollte hier wenn ihr wollte sich sofort
sterben dann macht und der tage
meditiert schön denkt sich ja ein
gefundenes fressen aber nicht mi amigo
ich werde ich werde schwer finden und
ich werde dafür sorgen dass du deine
gerechte strafe bekommt
es sei aber nicht zu fassen
etliche gefallen ok kann ich raus danke
mein gott wie viele kisten jetzt und
hier noch kein schild bitte hier
ja auch mein gott endlich es gibt ein
graz und der wirt werden bogen spannt
und kräftig als nicht nett er wenig
getrieben
ja da liegt doch scheiß um baustoff hin
dass voller klappt sagt du bist weg das
nehme ich mit
es ist einfach heftig leute im märz
gesehen ist wirklich höllisch aufpassen
einfach hoffen wir setzen jetzt hatte
ich die beste leistung die man hier
haben kann mit dir bewusst platte und
bei so viel arbeit und noch einen
schönen stein shot das ist nicht
schlecht bogen haben wir alles da aber
ihr habt gesehen man muss einfach auch
wenn man wenn er verfolgte aber weiter
kisten öffnen hoffen
du kannst du jetzt schön urlaub lieber
ab und laufen den amazon hinterher weil
so von unten ist natürlich ein tolles
fest
weg mit dem den who erstmal
durchschnaufen
ja ich versuche jetzt einfach mal so
zwischen den runden zu erzählen was
dieses wochenende passiert ist und zwar
wirklich einiges los freitagabend kam
max hat mich besucht also kein crafter
kam vorbei mein bruder dann werden
zusammen geburtstag gefeiert
für alle diese exklusiven ausschnitt vom
von der party haben wollte mich nur so
sehen wollen wir nicht wie ich aussehen
ich mein geburtstag feiern
wie können wir offen
es ist schöner vorbeischauen 35 der
kinder wahrscheinlich gehen die meisten
kennen da hatte ein video hochgeladen
geburtstagsparty mit sk oder seht ihr
das
hier dann samstag haben wir dann den
ganzen tag nach dem freitag hat echt
eine anstrengende partie war auffällig
und anstrengend sein plakat auf dem ein
schwert
und ja dann haben wir als ja sehr gut
dann habe ich halt dann uns erholt am
samstag haben wir abends wir abends
rausgegangen um diesen fehler zu machen
und ich weiß wie eine video gesehen habe
falls nicht schaut ihn euch an hoch mein
gott dieses liederkreis kleiner junge
bist im video oder so also prix
sternchen sst und das war echt krass wir
haben alles artig hin trocken so
bisschen leute gibt's auf dem dm keine
ahnung bis dahin trocken ein bisschen
auf einmal geht so ein typ hinter uns in
die büsche und pc optisch wir sehen da
und man sieht dass wir den film wir
reden ihm die kamera reden man sieht die
kamera werden die rettende hand gab
die war nicht versteckt und der läuft
einfach dazu chillig rein locker riesig
über dann fallen mir wenn ich immer so
business area danke den fall ihr tun und
ja dann
ich hab's erst gar nicht gecheckt ich
hab nur hat ja okay so ein seltsamer typ
das video läuft aber er hat einfach dann
ins gebüsch twitter center und die habe
ich so weg gesehen habe und dann wollt
ihr euch das nicht vorenthalten ich habe
keinesfalls dieser aufnahme genommen
weil der typ ist da gemacht hat weil ich
hier bloß stellen wollte sonst nicht
wusste ist bis zum schnitt nicht ich
habe es beim schnitt gesagt hey max guck
mal hier
lol und der post so richtig dreckig der
brauchst du aber nicht so raus alles
gefühle
na ja gut dann nehme jetzt ausländer
hier wo der kanal blog hätten schon mal
das ist auch für den sack so weg damit
damit ist die erste beendet wir schauen
einfach mal dass wir heute so ja keine
ahnung so zwei drei brüche machen
einfach aus gezieltes raus da ich wollte
heute eigentlich mit dr banks aufnehmen
für heute ihr wisst better together aber
das hat nicht geklappt weil er selbst
viel zu tun hatte und wir versuchen seit
tagen irgendwie immer so mal zusammen
aufzunehmen aber keine ahnung scheint es
immer aber es wird wohl so sein dass wir
heute abend dann aufnehmen können und
morgen die folge better together mit dr
banks kommt da kann es schon oder
freunden ich glaube nein oder raus 9999
einmal deutlich auf bildung
ob ich noch bis die dümmste tage meines
lebens da wieder hoch zu gehen aber iolo
jolo des 911 zufällig ist ich hasse es
weißt du ja ok treppchen schafft ja
danke danke gott ist dieses mal ist
diese momente mein gott ich hatte keine
chance aber nichts gehabt und sich da
einfach dieses schwert raus und dann
habe ich mir meinen arsch gerettet aber
treffe werde jetzt von dem ihr ein
bisschen korrekter nein die gehälter
laut es war auch richtig lustig alter
greift er uns da auf dem engen raum an
und wir können behaupten
nein ist dafür sieht man erstmal hier so
es geht weiter immer noch vor dem spd
immer noch keine weg zu dem effeff zu
dem druck der honig ist wirklich ganz
übersehen
hawking rob oakeshott haben dankeschön
das ist immer schön dieser spielmodus
bestand max man auch mal ja wenn kurs
gebe ich zu aber das spielt nicht so
leicht ist es nicht
usd hatte doch einfach sein sein charme
sorgt es übrigens nur crafting mensch
warum auch immer kann man das crafting
kurs gehe ich könnte dir überraschen
und er hat auch eine bessere waffe 1000
bessere rüstung aber wer mich erwischen
können weil wir uns ein bisschen früh
eingestellt haben so jetzt hoffentlich
schottens keine ab dass vermutlich auf
klassische sg aber das scheint nicht der
fall zu sein wir uns erstmal ein
bisschen regen hier bis zum spazieren
heute ist echt schwierig kurs geht
der schein aber auch laut zu sein oder
wenn er sich da so von mir ab wendet ich
würde dich doch ein bisschen liebe
machen mit dir ja da kann keiner blog
hätten wir das bringt ihm nicht auf dem
engen raum was heißt blockierten zudem
engen raum da habe ich trotzdem ich nur
so weit bewegen können dass das nichts
gebracht hat fast voll
jan smeekens mal rein gold hab ich ganz
ehrlich bei qs geht kann aber einfach so
oft kann man immer was ist so oft immer
von hinten angegriffen werden deswegen
sehe ich da nicht wirklich einen grund
so ein gold apfel aufzubewahren der
kompost
der brust von st der steckt einiges weg
ok haben wir noch einmal
ja
und das major mörder was kann der mensch
könne ja gut dann soll es eben keine
nutzt seine gegner versuchen daher kam
meego soll gar nicht schlecht gemacht
von dem schluss ich hab's überhaupt
nicht nein nicht jeder irgendwie so eine
scheiße vor mich hin steht der firma so
hinter mir
überraschung ok
ja ich habe auch gerade überhaupt keinen
überblick wie viel ich eigentlich schon
aufgenommen habe viel zeit weil ich bin
hier weil ich gesagt jetzt schon
versucht habe und ich weiß nicht welche
versuche ich neben werden das heißt das
video kann entweder exorbitante langen
werden oder superkurz das weiß noch
keiner
aber was wohl die allermeisten wissen
ist dass wir jetzt erstmal ins
deathmatch den nächsten fünfzehn
sekunden
zehn sekunden den sprung
neujahr leute mir auch so gut überlegt
sein wasser okay die ist ja meganisi
jetzt aber nicht die lava laufen
trotzdem dass selbst die hardware nicht
länger laufen
ich habe jetzt größere problem sagt ok
wo alte wieder noch wo an habe ich mich
darüber gebeugt habe von übergewicht
casino biochips sorry also ich sehe auch
nicht ein ganz ehrlich mir schenkt auch
niemand waffen und dann also ich kann
auch ziemlich man sagen psychopath nicht
ab jetzt gerne waffe bekommen jetzt
natürlich noch in die lava als ungefähre
letzte option
ansonsten ist die erledigt ja okay das
ist jetzt ein bisschen kürzer zu holen
hier ja
bitte den sohn erschossen
oh gott ohne witz
ja die gebühren ist so matschig ist ob
ich den ganzen tag mein kopf muss die
behinderten last eine positive bewertung
da wenn ihr mehr kurs gesehen wollte und
wenn ihr findet dass ich ein kleiner
biss zu